Germany is under pressure to supply
Ukraine with its most modern battle
tanks
what I in Germany's reluctant and why
are tanks seen as so crucial in the war
against Russia this is Inside Story
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
I'm Nick Clark Russia's invasion of
Ukraine is nearing its second year and
it's been a return to Conventional
Warfare in Europe something that would
have been unimaginable 12 months ago
while the death toll mounts a supply of
military aid 2 Kiev has become an
international political battle in itself
Germany is under pressure to allow the
supply of its modern leopard 2 tanks to
Ukraine the new defense minister gave
little away in his first meeting with
his U.S defense secretary counterpart
Lloyd Austin
during these times Germany and the U.S
are standing together when acting but
also during concrete questions maybe the
tanks the Patriot air defense or
multiple rocket launchers German systems
are proving itself in Ukraine well many
world political and business figures
have been meeting at the world economic
Forum in Davos where the issue of German
tanks for Ukraine has been hotly debated
both on stage and on the sidelines our
diplomatic correspondent James Bayes
reports on the discussions
the world economic Forum of Davos looks
at all the issues of the world but among
the EU and NATO leaders here a lot of
the discussions have been about Ukraine
of course and about weapons for Ukraine
president zielinski addressed the world
economic Forum by video link he called
for more air defense more tanks and the
focus has been very much on those tanks
and very much on Germany Germany has a
main battle tank called The Leopard two
but it's not just in German stocks
Germany has sold those tanks to many
other EU and NATO countries some of
those countries notably Poland would
like to give some of their tanks to
Ukraine but under the export regulations
when Germany sold them they have to get
German permission and that permission
has not come so far so a great deal of
pressure on the German Chancellor Olaf
Schultz who was here in Davos he was
asked specifically about the leopard two
tanks he dodged the question he said
that Germany had provided a great deal
of Weaponry in the first year year of
this war he said it would operate in
lockstep with its allies and I think
that means very much the United States
as well as the other NATO allies and of
course the U.S hasn't said it's
Abraham's main battle tank either to
Ukraine because it says it would be
difficult for the ukrainians to operate
in the terrain that exists on the ground
in Ukraine Chancellor Schultz also
saying that he wants to avoid at any
cost a full all-out war between NATO and
the NATO members and Russia and so
everything now moves I think after all
the discussions all this week that have
been taking place at Davos to Ramstein
that important meeting at the U.S Air
Base in Germany where defense ministers
will be meeting to decide what now to
give to Ukraine James Bates with that
update from Davos so let's take a closer
look at the specs of the leopard 2 tank
it's been upgraded several times since
it was launched in 1979. currently it's
used by 13 European armies The Leopard 2
is valued for its maneuverability it's
lighter than other comparable models the
tank has recent Battlefield experience
NATO forces in Afghanistan use them and
leopard tanks Germany are Supply to
other nations require approval from
Berlin before they can be re-exported to
a third country and that means the tanks
cannot be sent to Ukraine without
Germany's permission
oh
all right let's bring in our guests now
joining us live from Wiltshire in the
United Kingdom retired British Major
General Arthur dinaro he's also a former
Middle East advisor to the UK Ministry
of Defense from London
is a senior lecturer in security and
development at King's College London and
from Berlin I'm pleased to say Benares
is joining us the founder and
editor-in-chief of bne intelli news a
warm welcome to you all uh General De
Niro if I may start with you because I
just want to examine just why there's
such an intense focus on this issue of
Tanks one might think that Tank's a part
of a bygone era certainly to a Layman
anyway because in this age of long-range
Precision missiles uh you'd think that
they weren't as potent as they once were
but I presume that's not the case
they're still very valid on the
Battleground
yes very valid
um please bear in mind that you're
listening to a very uh ancient armchair
General and you need to take that with
all with a prince of salt so
um having tanks on the battlefield
um contributes to what we call the all
arms battle and it's the integration of
that all arms battle that makes
um an attacking force or a defending
Force um much more potent
um the ukrainians have got some good
tanks
um but but as we have seen that they're
not that much better than the the
Russians and we have seen how damaged
the Russians tanks could be with this
latest anti-tank Weaponry that Ukraine
has been supplied with these modern
tanks particularly the the leopard the
Challenger and the Abrams all have very
sophisticated protection against most of
these
um modern weaponry and having them on
the battlefield in support of the
Infantry and under um the long-range
support of artillery and air is a game
changer
right a game changer in what quantity
General would they be required to be a
game changer would you say
in reference to the the very Gallant
offer of Britain's Squadron of Tanks 14
tanks
um we we have to look at much greater
numbers
um way back when
um we we went to um
to
rescue Kuwait to liberate Kuwait from
Saddam Hussein's Army we had uh the way
the Allies had thousands of Tanks then
the British had over 150 there
um so the offer of 14 is is very
symbolic and we were first there doing
it and we hope that this might um pull
the others in and I hope it does because
14 is not enough
indeed and Donatella I think I'd be
right in saying the tanks would be the
most powerful direct weapon provided to
Ukraine so far even though at the moment
the numbers fall somewhere short to what
is required certainly by Ukraine
uh yes and of course to that we have to
add the the himas which have proven very
effective as a sort of long-range
artillery system so I think we shouldn't
forget about about those as well and
what is interesting is how much the
hamar is you know where he helped uh to
turn the tides in Ukraine's favor so I
think with that uh this clearly shows
that when tanks or other sort of Western
military equipment is delivered to
Ukraine it can really have an impact on
the battlefield that's why the delivery
of these uh tanks is so relevant uh and
and I would agree with the previous
speaker that it really would help uh to
sort of um assist Ukraine in trying to
sort of carry out more effective
offensive operations and also be able to
uh operate more effectively in defensive
positions as a kind of also some kind of
more mobile artillery force uh and uh at
the moment I think this is very
important and that it also comes
together with additional artillery
ammunition and also possibly you know
fighter jets so that uh the whole
combination of armed forces can operate
in a more effective offensive manner
right and Ben Harris what about the
Russian capability what would it mean
for the Russian side of things if you
know conval large convoys of Tanks
joined a Ukrainian offensive how would
it change things do you think
I think it would be significant as the
general said if enough tanks were sent
in a in number to to the battlefield I
mean you have to put this into the
context why is this coming up now and
the battle now has sort of ground down
to uh stalemate I mean in September we
had this remarkable offensive
counter-offensive by the ukrainians in
the hakif region and they broke through
the Russian defenses and then went like
a knife through butter pushing them back
liberating hundreds of kilometers and
then shortly at the end of that month
they uh they recaptured cast on as well
but now now the fighting has come down
there Russians have done their partial
mobilization they brought 300 000 fresh
troops into the uh into the field and
the front line has stabilized and you
know the the epicenter of the fighting
now is around
um in the donbass region and and solidar
which apparently has just Fallen to to
the Russian side
um but that fight at Buffalo has been
going on for months and we're talking
you know a couple of meters a day if
that it goes backwards and forwards and
so the two two sides are now butting
heads but nobody has the advantage if
you were to bring in these powerful
tanks these offensive weapons then that
would make a huge difference if you
bring them in in another number because
then you can smash through the you can
go on the offensive and attack the
Russian defenses and push them back
Poland uh president Davos yesterday
called on the west to send a hundred of
these leopard twos and I think there are
around 2 000 of them scattered
throughout Europe a pollen itself has
about 250 and 100 leopards on the field
would make all the difference because
again as the general said that there are
about 20 tons heavier than anything the
Russians have got the t-72s which is the
Workhorse of the Russian side and the
armor on them is significant and Russia
doesn't have things like the
American-made javelins that the
ukrainians had in order to take these
tanks out so that they would be a real
game changer and I think that's what
people are looking at is like they're
getting frust traded at this deadlock a
hundred thousand people have died on
both sides with no one making any
progress and so the ukrainians are
saying right enough with the defensive
weapons with the Patriots with the
javelins that you sent us these have
been very useful give us some offensive
weapons so that we can actually win this
war and push the Russians back over the
1991 borders okay in general so we've
been alluded to it just then but any big
scale offensive would would need by
Ukraine that is would need to be backed
up by air and ground support right
yes that and of course the tank gives
the ground forces maneuverability which
um as bends just
told us you know it has grown to a halt
um in order to maneuver we've got to
have mobile well protected hard-hitting
Firepower and the only thing that can
deliver that
is the tank and the leopard is is
perfectly formed for that one
um and of course it's handed by so it's
it it's not going to take long to get it
into Ukraine and
and it is relatively easy to operate
compared to some aspects certainly of
Abrams and and of our challenger but
it's the maneuverability and the
protection that that affords this
very hard hitting bitter kid that makes
it such a potent force all right so
that's the kind of the battlefield
landscape Donatella why do you think uh
Germany has been just so reticent so
reluctant in committing to providing
these german-made tanks
well first of all it's important to know
that the reluctances come primarily from
the chancellor or the Schultz I think he
and and others in his party are very
worried about uh about an escalation
about the potential conflict between
Russia and NATO and Germany being
involved in that and now I think a bit
exaggerated because uh you know Germany
could even start by authorizing uh the
delivery of these leopards by those
countries which have them already and
that wouldn't necessarily involve
Germany itself there is a lot of concern
in Germany of being seen uh you know in
certain quarters has been seen as being
sort of part of one of our so-called
offensive but I think that is is really
uh the wrong approach but there is I
think a very strong in a way sort of
pacifist tradition in Germany and what
is interesting is that uh Olive Schultz
you know in his youth really was part of
this pacifist tradition and and he was
sort of very much a sort of anti-nato uh
politician although so you know he
evolved a lot throughout his political
career and as we know he gave his famous
speech on uh you know in at the start of
the war in Ukraine where he talked about
you know how Germany had to change its
course and realm again in the face of
the Russian threat but at the same time
I think there is a very strong
reluctance and I think he's probably
looking at public opinion which is
slowly shifting and there is increasing
support for so-called freeing the
leopards uh but I think that uh um you
know deep inside I think is very
reluctant to to see Germany because of
its history during the second world war
and also during the Cold War when
Germany was divided occupied uh by the
Soviet Union and Germany could be a
potential theater of war you know that
this can repeat itself so there is a
very sort of ingrained historical sort
of narrative that is strong in certain
quarters in Germany uh that in a way is
putting a break but I think that but
he's uh you know that Chancellor is
increasingly under pressure from inside
his own Coalition by members of the
green party and the FTP yeah let me just
bring Ben in there there are some
contradictions here on there because you
have this kind of this German reluctance
but on the other hand back in February
last year Olaf Schultz was you know
announcing this historical turning point
for for Germany to ramp up its defenses
which many said that was
um you know something extraordinary
since they haven't done that since World
War II and and even today we're hearing
about the the new German defense
minister talking up Germany's need to
strengthen defenses
yeah but the key word there is defense
and what we're talking about here is a
war with Russia which is you know the
tanks are offensive weapons and look to
step back and understand the context of
this and why I mean as Donald said I
said of course Germany has this history
I mean it uniquely almost uniquely in
Europe has fought the Russians and lost
and doesn't want to repeat that
experience I mean they're more sensitive
than anybody else
but um the overrunning goal of NATO in
general in Germany in particular is not
to help the ukrainians beat the Russians
first and foremost it's it's first and
foremost is to prevent a World War to
prevent a direct conflict between NATO
and uh Russia no one wants to go there
and that's one of the reasons why we've
been pouring in defensive weapons in
order to make sure that Ukraine doesn't
lose this war which is not quite the
same thing as making sure it wins this
war and we've now reached the point with
the stalemate where everyone is getting
frustrated and hundreds of thousands of
people are dying
um so there's now a push to abandon that
and to give
um give Ukraine some offensive weapons
to actually change the balance and the
reason why Germany in particular is so
nervous because it's unpredictable how
the Kremlin will react
um so far Putin's indicated that he
hasn't got a problem with NATO supplying
defensive weapons in so much as that
Russia still has the advantage on the
field both in terms of artillery and men
and that he can just grind the
ukrainians down and if you put offensive
weapons that change the the tide of the
war until Ukraine's Advantage then all
the new really scary possibilities
including tactical nuclear weapons
appear and that's really what's behind
this hesitancy and it's not just Germany
I mean Jan stoltenberg from NATO said
right at the beginning is conflict our
top priority is to avoid World War III
our second priority is to help Ukraine
defend itself and it's doing an amazing
job something that nobody was expecting
right General De Niro do you can concur
with that or you know there is the other
argument that defeat for Ukraine that in
itself could lead to World War III
yes it could and it's incredibly
difficult to predict which way it's
going to fall and whether the supply of
these tanks which are
um in in the main aim uh offensive but
also are hugely useful in any form of
defensive posture
um is going to affect that balance and
um
I'm you know I I'm finding it very
difficult to predict that
and so Ben we talked about the United
States there and and Germany themselves
have said that you know the U.S haven't
sent any tanks and if they do then then
we will why do you think the US is is
reticent as well
it's the same fears I mean nobody wants
to start third world war with Russia
because then it you know it all the
whole It all becomes extremely
unpredictable and um becomes extremely
scary with the nuclear exchange between
the major powers and the the Americans
too um have also followed this policy of
supplying largely defensive weapons
um the peer pressure amongst Europeans
and you've got some countries in Europe
like the Polish uh and the Baltic states
in particular that are very anti-russian
very pro-ukraine want to see these heavy
weapons put in and others um sitting on
the fence and people are hungry of
course are friends with Putin but for
the Americans I mean Schultz is trying
to pass the buck he's getting a lot of
pressure from all the other uu members
particularly the more aggressive ones to
send these tanks and Germany has the um
the largest defense sector in Europe and
so
um everybody's got German weapons and
you can't export them to Ukraine without
a German permission and Schultz said um
this week I think it was just yesterday
that if the Americans sent the Abraham
tanks their tanks then Germany would
follow suit and so he's passing them out
to the Americans but then the Americans
have said and I think your reporter said
that they're reluctant to send their
tanks too because they're not suitable
in the in the terrain you know we're
talking about a huge flat agricultural
land this is like the perfect terrain
for upper tanks and I do and moreover
necessary because there's so little
cover so it sounds a bit like an excuse
and again on the English side at the UK
side rather
um they've sent 14 tanks which is a
gesture uh like the general said you
have to send a much much more 50 100
tanks would make a difference so we're
not seeing that too so everyone's
pulling their punches I think at
Ramstein tomorrow what we'll see is that
Schultz will cave to the pressure that
he's under but there'll be a token
gesture or a dozen efforts that will be
sent from Poland say
um in order to take the pressure off to
to do something more to help the
ukrainians but again not going far
enough not sending a battalion of like
100 tanks that would actually make a big
difference on the battlefield because of
the fear of provoking Russia to go to
the next level doing Mass mobilization
putting a million people into the field
and overrunning Ukraine and then start
taking our ammo dumps in in Poland or
really extreme reactions like that yeah
and domitilla just coming back to this
point about a potential Russian defeat
especially in the light of what the the
former Russian president Dimitri
Medvedev has said that the defeat of a
nuclear power in a conventional War May
trigger a nuclear war
well I think that they've been
threatening the use of nuclear war now
for several months uh even before the
start of the war Putin was talking about
this risk if there was an attempt on on
Pioneer uh by the ukrainians I think
that uh you know we have to take that
into consideration but it shouldn't be a
sort of a self-deterrent I think that we
have to be cautious but I I think that
it would be highly unlikely that Russia
sort of starts uh uh sort of a major
nuclear exchange with with the West I
mean there is a possibility they could
use of course tactical nuclear weapons
but uh I mean what would they really
achieve and I think that the Americans
have made it clear that if there is a
use of tactical nuclear weapons in
Ukraine the Americans and NATO would
intervene even with conventional forces
and there would be a very high risk to
the regime of President Putin so I think
that often many of these uh um
statements are are in empty threats but
they have to be taken seriously and as
the previous speakers noted you know the
question of escalation is in everyone's
mind so you know there is caution but at
the same time you know we now have to
consider that we are at this sort of
turning point because Russia is ready to
mobilize a very high number of of
soldiers it is engaging it's all its
entire sort of um economic
infrastructure and Industrial
infrastructure towards the war effort
the production of Tanks uh that you know
and other kinds of military equipment
that could be potentially used for very
much to Russia in the battlefield okay
we're just running out of time I just
want to finally come to to General De
Niro sending all these Munitions to
Ukraine it crosses my mind that it's not
just depleting countries of their own
defense capability and doesn't it make
the world a more dangerous place in that
sense too
I don't think so um what I think really
is important here is that the speed of
decision making because there's no doubt
that to change the the whole temper of
this conflict and to get it resolved
um we need to support the ukrainians
with tanks and
um the American consent as in
um in smaller numbers because clearly
the the distances and also the training
on the Abrams is more difficult
um the British are already planned to
send um a squadron and the the the real
answer is for the leopards to be
um supplied by the various countries
who've got them because they're there on
the borders ready to go and they are
much um easier really to operate all
right we'll watch closely how this pans
out in the coming days we have to leave
it there thank you to all our guests
Arthur dinaro domitiles agromoso and Ben
Ares and thank you too for watching you
can see the program again anytime by
visiting our website Al jazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
Facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash AJ Inside Story and you
can also join the conversation on
Twitter our handle is at AJ Inside Story
Romina Clark and the whole team here
it's goodbye